hello everyone I hope you're having a
great Saturday now I know most of you
are probably outside enjoying the
outside world but for those of you who
are at home on a Saturday watching
YouTube videos I decided to do another
game from round six of the 2018
candidates tournament here we have
chakra Irma media off with the white
pieces against Vladimir Kramnik and it's
a of course every game is important but
here both of them have three points so
whoever wins this game might end up in
the lead in the tournament so let's see
this game mama D ro has the white pieces
and he didn't like that game Aragon
played against kramnik no I mean he
doesn't want to play efore and allow
kramnik to go for the Berlin so he will
go d4 and a la Kramnik to go for his
Queens gambit declined and before we
start with the game we should we should
definitely enjoy some nice photos as I
do have some fresh photos from the
tournament here we have this is before
the the start of the game before move
one you can see a very nice setting
there we have here a nice close-up of
Vladimir Kramnik here we have another
nice close-up of Vladimir Kramnik here
we have mama DDR of it seems that
already before the game even started he
already almost finished his bottle of
water and for the end we have a nice
mysterious photo as you can see there's
definitely something very wrong with
chronics bottle of water which which
could be the reason for some of his
decisions during the game but okay that
being said let's see this game like I
said mama dro opens with the d4 we have
d5 c4 e6 Knight to c3 and Knight to f6
the Queens gambit declined seek after
Sun d5 the exchange variation Knight
captures efore Knight captors and c3b
captures on c3 and now c5 we have looked
to be one mommy geography immediately
takes the advantage of that semi open B
file and here Bishop to e7 I've seen
some games in this position where black
actually tried Queen a5 to go for the c3
pawn and DA to pawn but you would you
will win the a to pawn and there is no
real danger
your queen getting trapped but after
Bishop to d2 Queen captures the Knight
f3 black-white really got a lot of
advantage and won most of the games I
think I've seen only one game where
black actually won this but that was
against very very low rated players so a
troop to be one Bishop to e7 Bishop to
b5 check Bishop to d7 and now Bishop to
d3 seemingly losing a tempo but not
really in this bishop light square
Bishop is much more useful and e3 and
now black will definitely have to do
something about this b7 pawn as it's
undefended so seek after Sundy for seek
after Sun before and now Knight to c6
defending the b7 pawn would atactic as
now the d4 pawn is also attacked so
Bishop back to e 2 again losing a temple
but now the Queen is again defending d4
and now black again has to do something
about that
pawn and b7 and a chronic ear again
defends it would a tactic Rock the c8
and now of course you can't capture it
because after we capture black was
simply capture on d4 Queen captures rook
captures and c1 with check black is much
better here probably even winning
so after rook to c8 Knight to f3
defending the d4 pawn and now Queen to
a5 check Kramnik offers to enter the
endgame Bishop to d2 and now Bishop to
b4 we have rook to be to defending the a
to pawn now Bishop captures Queen
captures Queen captures King captures
and the Queen's are off the board so
it's a perfectly fine position for both
white and black nothing you know nothing
wrong with either position and here
finally Knight to a5 Kramnik addresses
the issue of the b7 pawn and the ideal
setup for black would definitely be to
push a 6 it will be 5 make a nice
outpost here on c4 for this night and if
white loves it that's definitely what
black will do so rook back to B 1 as
mama Dara doesn't wanna long Knight to
c4 check forcing forcing the the
exchange of a bishop or Knight
so King to e7 we have rook H 2 c1
and now f6 h for not allowing Kramnik to
pull g5 rook H to d8
now Bishop to d3 a6 preparing that b5
King to e3 getting the King to a more
active square b5 now and here we have g4
Bishop - he ate and now this the idea of
Bishop to 8 is to create an attack on
this d4 pawn next gromek will plan to go
Knight to c6 and pile up on the d4 pawn
Knight the g1 would the idea of removing
the Knight to e2 to help out with the
defense of the d4 pawn Knight to c6
attacking it and Knight to e2 defending
and here rook to d6 preparing to double
up rooks and the D file to pile up on
the d4 pawn even more rook to d1 rook to
d8 now doubling up and now Bishop to see
to getting the bishop out of the way so
now even the rock helps out with the
defense of the d4 pawn and here we have
Knight to a5 with the idea of getting a
nice outpost here for this Knight
kicking the King away with check and
winning the d4 pawn so now Bishop back
to d3 as now the night is no longer on
c6 so black can capture on d4 and here a
chronic repeats Knight to c6 here mama D
off again plays Bishop - see - and here
this repetition of Bishop to c2 and
Knight to c6 to a5 is basically Mahmud
Arabs offering a draw here and if pranic
would repeat Knight to a5 it would be a
one more Bishop to d3 it would be a
threefold repetition at the game would
end in a draw but Kramnik is not
interested in a draw Kramnik is
interested in a game so he pushes h5 ok
g g5 f captures and g5 and now and in
between move e5 gaining more space and
perhaps perhaps that some maybe this
night could go to g3 maybe to e4 and
then maybe end up on d6 so rook moves
and now H captures and g5 here we have
h4 and the chronic could be chronic
definitely created a very nice path bone
here and now of course first g6
not allowing this Bishop Bishop on eh to
become active Knight to a5 again going
for c4 rook b2 c1 and now rook to c7
we have Bishop to d3 and
this is basically the first moment of
the game were were were something went
wrong here
chronic definitely definitely must
exchange this rook rook captures rook
captures and then developed this bishop
now this Bishop is very active here and
also he will be able to play rook to h8
to support his past pawn and that's
basically it
but after this Bishop to d3 move he
decided to play rugby to c8 for some
reason and now mama Dara simply exchange
it rook captures rook captures and now
rook to h1 and there is no way to defend
the h4 pawn so here chronic just
blundered upon but okay you know what's
one point in in the candidates night the
c-4 chick now we have King to f4 and now
Knights to be two attacking the bishop
bishop moves and now b4 rook captures on
h4 nanometre grabs that pawn and now
Knight to d1 attacking the f2 pawn f3 of
course Knight back to c3 and now Knight
captures pawn captures and okay now here
Kramnik does have a past C pawn but rope
to h2 and with the bishop both rook and
Bishop guarding the city square there's
no real chance of this point ever going
any further rook to c8 we have King to
e3 and now Bishop to b5 f for Bishop to
c4 and now rook to h7 going for the g7
pawn rook to g8 and now a3 a5 both
players don't want their pawns and the
light square so the points won't be
targets and now Bishop the c2 I'm not
allowing
Kramnik to play Bishop to b3 and pull
this pawn king to d7 with which the idea
that that the king should come to c6 and
then d5 and get get activated but here
and it's a very nice maneuver that Mommy
deriv does here you should you should
maybe remember they said as it might be
useful in your own games here a
temporary pawn sacrifice your mama drf
plays d5 the idea of d5 is that you
wanna okay you want to open up this d4
square for a king so
King becomes more active and at this
point is on a darks worse we were gonna
win it sooner or later anyway and this
is definitely the best way to go about
it as it also restricts the movement of
the black king so the five Bishop
captures and now King to d4 Bishop to 82
now King captures on c3 so the pawn
sacrifice was only temporary King to c6
and now rook back to h2 the threat of
course being rocked a forecheck picking
up the bishop opening up a discovered
attack from the rook King to c5 not
allowing the check and now rook to d2 we
have rope to h8 now kramnik wants to
activate his own Brooke roof to d7
attacking the g7 pawn and now rook to h3
check King Tubby to and now Bishop to d5
my MIDI RF captures that naamam gyro is
up two points and there is no there is
no real way that Kramnik would be able
to save this position but you know
Kramnik blundered upon maybe maybe
Mahmud arrow will blunt or pawn king to
d4 and now Rock to h7 of course black
can't can't afford a the exchange of
rooks Rock to g3 and now Rock to h5 with
the very simple threat but a deadly one
rook to g5 and black will either have to
trade rooks or remove the rock and then
mama drf has a rogue behind the passed
pawn and the bishop is also guarding the
g6 pawn so there's really nothing
Kramnik can do here
RUP - G - we have rook of course to g5
that was the threat f2 now comes g7 and
this was kremlings I see chronics last
idea Bishop to e4
here mom Yara brings the Queen into the
game we have rook captures on c2 which
check King to be three and now rook the
c3 check King to a four and now chronics
a last sneaky sneaky attempt in this
game ripped the c5 I rope to c5 wood the
idea that maybe okay mama Derek knows
that he's winning maybe he'll lower his
guard maybe maybe just maybe I tried to
find one move that would allow Kramnik
to pull this off but maybe if my Medea
of played Queen to d8 check you know
with the idea that maybe he's winning
maybe
doesn't care how he wins then kramnik
would have keen to see four and now
white is lost there is no defense
against both the bishop to see to
checkmate and Bishop to see six
checkmate so you can't defend both
threats white would have to do something
terrible give up the Queen and the end
then lose the game terribly but of
course mama off didn't fall for this
after work the c5 he played rook to g2
simply preventing Bishop to c2 and now
comes Bishop to f3 again Kramnik hopes
for for some miracle that he pulls off
Bishop to d1 but here Queen to d8 check
and it was in this position that
Vladimir Kramnik resigned the game now
in any move losses and now the the idea
that Romney had before of King to c4
loses immediately rook to c2 checkmate
so yeah after Queen to d8 Kramnik had
enough and he resigned the game so
before I forget I did prepare the final
standings after round six so here they
are
I have them right here so after six
rounds of the 2018 candidates tournament
we have Fabiano Caruana in first place
with four points Mahmoud Europe after
winning this game against Kramnik also
four points sharing first place with
Fabiano both of them with a very nice
rating performance of 2900 and 10
then comes Kramnik in third place yeah
he did lose two games but he also won
two games so he is far up in the
standings then we have Greece choke and
also ding leerin three of them with
three points then Wesley so and eleven
are Union which two and a half points
and Sergei Carrick in 2016 Challenger to
Magnus Carlsen in last place with two
points and yeah there are a lot a lot of
interesting here things here to check
out in the standings for example Caruana
mamedyarov
and Dingley were and are the only three
players so far without a single loss but
the England being in fifth place it's
because he's drawn all his all of his
games so basically he's pulling pulling
a giri and another another thing
everyone thought that Oregon would crush
this tournament but here here he is
after six rounds only two and a half
points but it's it's still very early in
the tournament so
anything could happen a winner - and
he's back you know fighting for first
place so I wouldn't rule out anyone even
Sergei Karekin so yeah
those were the standings and that was
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank John Martha's Michal
root go Mario and sin osa and of course
Kenneth McKay of Scotland thank you very
much I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon